hi I'm David per share CEO post helpers
and I am answering king alex 178 s
question what could I a student from
high school do to support the economy of
my country well Alex or King um I think
the most important thing you can do is
look at yourself as a creator and not a
consumer right more watchlist television
read more books look at how other people
create and try and sort of approved and
sort of use what they're doing to inform
your work and remember that the things
that you do have to say matter you
there's a whole world of people that
can't wait to hear what you have to say
and just sort of think about that so
good luck and thank you good